this is Jonathan Ferguson keeper of
firearms and artillery at the Royal
armories Museum in the UK which houses a
collection of thousands of iconic
weapons from throughout history and this
week he's taking a look at some of the
VR Weaponry from bone lab I don't think
you can beat for for people who are
interested in Firearms historic or
otherwise the the ability to actually
interact with firearm to the point that
as we've just seen you can go from
shooting the weapon to spinning it round
and using it as a club make sure to
subscribe and check out our previous VR
episodes where Jonathan took a look at
the guns of H3 VR and if you like this
kind of content we've got a brand new
season of Loadout airing on the channel
right now new episodes will launch every
Sunday and you can already check out our
most recent episode all about how games
face the tricky problem of adapting lmgs
into their digital Arenas right let's
take a look at the weapons of bone lab
foreign
this is a nicely modeled akm such as I
have here uh this one happens to have
the bayonet still attached this one is
modeled essentially brand new so the
Finish is fully intact the wood is a
nice shiny varnished finish whereas the
example I have here is extremely tired
there's lost a lot of finish
and the laminated wood is very worn
almost looks like Driftwood on this
thing this has been through the walls
literally I suspect although we don't
know the history of this particular one
so nicely modeled gun works pretty well
we have the magic
magazine getting sucked into the gun
thing which I'm on the face of it not a
fan of but I'm sure there's a good
gameplay reason for it the writing of
the charging handle not a good idea to
do in real life if you sort of
let it slide forward there's a there's a
chance of it not going all the way
forward in which case the gun won't
shoot of course it's going to be very
frustrating in any kind of game really
to let you do that because normally you
can't of course you just press a button
and the gun gets reloaded magically here
you're doing it manually to model the
realism of having to always pull it back
and let it go from Full travel which is
what you should always do would just get
annoying I suspect so that's probably
why the cartridge case objection on this
and indeed the rate of fire seems to
fluctuate and is too high I'd say it's
about 700 something like that it's a bit
high for an AK and it should be more
like 600s that suggests to me that if
that the stuttering that I'm hearing in
the rate of fire is a real thing and
that each shot is being fired at a
slightly different spacing or maybe
there are two different space I don't
know be interesting to know what's going
on under the hood as it were to make
this thing seem a bit bit high speed and
a bit stuttery
foreign
I've Just Seen A reload there where we
had a Fresh Magazine brought up to the
gun and somehow the magazine is already
on the gun just dropped off and you put
on the new one okay as an option that's
fine for me I would much prefer to be
forced to remove the magazine so in this
case with the AK you do the Polish
method of
hitting the paddle with the with the
Fresh Magazine or however you want to do
it you know you don't get to play with
that real world aspect of the firearm if
it just automatically happens I think
you can probably override that and bump
the magazine off I'm sure I've seen that
with um phone works before
[Music]
nice little moment there with an
ejection a deliberate objection of a
live round straight up in the air which
then came back down and bounced off the
gun all sorts of fun you can uh you can
have with when something is fully
modeled and you have full range of
motion and ability to draft something
anywhere not just fixed points that the
gun that the game makes you and grab
onto all sorts of possibilities most of
them not very helpful for actually
progressing through a game probably
foreign
I don't think you can beat for for
people who are interested in Firearms
historic or otherwise the the ability to
actually interact with firearm to the
point that as we've just seen
you can go from shooting the weapon to
spinning it round and using it as a club
that's that's something with a 2d game
just can't do I don't remember ever
seeing a gun clubbed this is something
that happened in the 17th 19th centuries
to Club your musket was to literally
spin it round and use it as a club that
kind of emergent tactical approach is
fairly unique to this kind of VR game
okay
okay so obviously the the skeleton is
just a bit of fun the skin that's being
used here but it does raise a minor
point that the where where the hand
bones of the hand are wrapped around
this very well realized Remington 870 by
the way the grip Is Not Great you really
want the the web of the hand to be over
the sort of ball line of the gun to give
it maximum support very important if
you're going to fire this thing
one-handed as we just saw done if you've
had that looser grip and you've fired a
shotgun like this one-handed loaded with
anything like um Buckshot or um or slug
it's probably going to come out of that
hand depending on how good your
grip strength is so that that proper
placement on whatever firearm it might
be is something that's I suppose a
little bit cheated in most things
because you're just essentially artwork
even if it's in 3D you just get it right
because you have your reference and you
make sure that it's right where you are
having to in real time attach a hand to
a gun in a certain place it's going to
be a lot harder to make sure that that
lines up in the way that you would want
it to be lined up not that everyone uses
guns correctly of course but it would
stand out as I say if you're firing a 12
gauge shotgun with one hand um you're
probably going to regret it at the very
least it'll be uncomfortable if you
didn't have a very good sound grip on it
perfectly doable though
foreign
[Music]
with the the mini sorry the micro Uzi
we've got an older type
here the folding spot stop
the traditional Uzi magazine release the
cocking handle on the top of the gun
this one also has a slightly longer
compensated Barrel on it this is
actually a copy the one in the game is
the modernized current version with all
those different features anyway that's
counted by the bike it handles pretty
much as I would expect it to and we have
a really very cool dual wheeled and dual
wield reload so something I was
wondering about with a with a VR game
that models to a high degree of fidelity
how do you reload those empty guns and
the answer is you lay one on top of the
other to free up your hand to get the
spare magazines out it's just
very cool actually
nice to see the venerable M1 Garand
great to see that in this game looks
like a good job as well got some punch
to it the the sound effect the the way
it's handling too and of course the
classic ping
the clip coming out slightly ruined
there by its um somehow sticking on top
of the gun rather than flinging clear
not sure what that's about but I suppose
glitches are to be expected when you're
dealing with multiple degrees of freedom
and actual operation of a virtual weapon
rather than just animating it I I must
admit the I understand the the need for
sort of expedited reloads and things
where you don't actually have to push
something all the way in to get it to
work but it's particularly disappointing
in this case because you can't
accidentally guaran thumb yourself
I suspect every every Firearms
Enthusiast would be doing deliberately
just to just for the sake of doing it
now this rifle has a bayonet fitted I
wondered if that was going to be you the
one that wonder I'm absolutely certain
it was going to be usable um and that's
one of the better depictions of a
bayonet use that you really feel like
you're having to put some force in to
cause cause the injury everything about
that stabbing with a with a knife on the
end of a gun kind of worked as you'd
expect you definitely it definitely
wasn't the press button to make someone
fall down thing that we often see
foreign
first thing I noticed with this AR-15
I'll call it there's no evidence of it
being automatic that I've seen yet
there's some bolt bounce which is really
intriguing never seen that before I
guess these guys have been watching slow
motion video and seen that basically all
firearms there is a bounce after the
bolt the bolt hits the uh in this case
the barrel extension and bounces back
very slightly now the extent of Bolt
bounce I'm seeing here I think would
probably be a problem for functioning
because if the bounce is too too
exaggerated and you're well certainly an
automatic fire where the rate of fire is
very high of course the bolt can still
be can be in the wrong position when the
hammer next Falls and then the Gun Won't
fire because the firing pin isn't
impacted in the correct way but the the
just the prospects of this raises of I
don't know using VR to test out firearm
designs potentially maybe haven't heard
of anyone doing that but if the Fidelity
were to get good enough then you could
you could model stuff and test it out
the other thing I noticed with this gun
that I haven't with others as yet is
change it changing reports from shot to
shot so we've got random changes in rate
of fire with some of these guns and in
this case I'm also hearing different
pitch of shots without changing location
without changing in theory ammunition or
anything else the closest uh example I
can give you is the the good old aliens
pulse rifle which I'm always referencing
where the the firing tone which makes it
sound incredibly cool is up and down as
it's fine which doesn't make any sense
but is cool as hell in a Sci-Fi movie
and that's a I'm getting a version of
that here so shot to shot it's like
maybe or maybe it's only varying between
two two pitches but still model wise
this is very close to an M16 A4
depending on whether it's automatic or
not depending what the marks on the
receiver are but all the details are
consistent with an M16 for or a civilian
semi-automatic version of it
Chris Vector always makes me a bit sad
because we don't have one yet um maybe
we will one day as we've noted before
very unusual design attempting to
overcome the or mitigate the problem of
felt recoil with a weird diving bolt not
particularly relevant in its video game
use I suppose it could be more relevant
in a VR sense but it's hard for me to
get a sense of whether it's whether it's
helping in any way whether it's even
modeled the bolt May well just go back
and forth in this not real version
ratify is very high now it is high on
the vector sure if this might be a
little too high even now I've noticed on
the other guns in the game that they
have this magical vacuum effect where
you get to a certain distance and the
magazine gets gets drawn into the gun
it's not happening on this one
presumably because the magazine well is
so tall and so you are it is possible to
fumble and bubble it about and not get
it into the magazine well which for me
is a plus I I like the fact that you
have to be precise with a with a VR
reload so I enjoy that more on this than
I do on the other guys have to say
foreign
[Music]
here we see another dual wield reload
the one one we will have seen or you
will have seen rather in movies and
similar where Jackson magazine you
holster your empty one weapon to give
you to free up your hand to reload them
both really cool that you can interact
with your own self in that way the
weapon in this case is the well not
really a weapon to be fair this or at
least this model this is the Ruger Mark
III Target which is very much for
putting holes in paper a firearm but um
not necessarily a weapon so our Target
Model the only only Mark III that we
have we have Mark ones and twos coming
out of barriers but only one mark three
has this very cool looking fluted heavy
Target Barrel you can see it's only a
small caliber bullet so the game is
modeling uh everything else is identical
James modeling it uh well I think if I
was incredibly nitpicky I might say that
the bolt is coming out of the back of
the gun maybe a bit too far but that's
really reaching for things to criticize
is there magazine looks like the
magazine should that 2-2 magazines tend
to be quite different than
10 to 5 magazines and it works as
advertised so we have a slide or a bolts
in this case release
on the side there
all right finale M4 super 90 showing
this off because it's a recent
acquisition to the Contemporary part of
this collection here at the Royal
armories identical configuration to the
one in the game and almost identical
there are a few dimensional differences
proportion between this grip stock
assembly and the receiver is is slightly
off I think this large pin for the
lifter here is not as large as it ought
to be in the game unless there's some
build standard difference that I'm not
aware of but honestly it's a really good
job and functions as you would wish it
to doesn't have the funky twist and the
slide but stock because they're not
don't seem to be adjustable in this game
again because of the sucking the
ammunition to the gun thing it doesn't
look like
I didn't get any inert rounds to play
with but it's a museum collection we
don't play with guns
um you can't drop around into the
chamber and close it I don't think
because it's not how the loading in the
game works and because there isn't a
magazine you can't kind of insert that
and even the magazines get sucked into
the gun but yeah it works nicely this
this um or the gameplay um kind of
irrelevant with what the gun is but the
ability to actually
contact the environment with the gun
yeah they guns and games feel so
disconnected from the world around you
normally but when you can accidentally
catch the gun on a window ledge or a
corner or you have to think about the
length of your gun so maybe you would
um you would even do something called
short stocking where you'd have it over
your shoulder to move through a space
and then you bring it into the aim like
that all those kind of possibilities for
not only fun but training you know we're
not there yet I don't think but really
exciting for those of us who like this
kind of thing
everything
all right well this is fun for those of
us at the Royal armories because we deal
of course with all sorts of arms and
armor that's that's what we're here for
so to see the um a not historically
accurate but a very nicely nicely
realized wooden and metal shield
complete with the studs of nails I
should say screws I think as well that
are holding the bits of it together it
looks like a real object it's being held
like a real object and being used
alongside the Benelli resting it on top
of the shield some some great sort of
emergent possibilities with this kind of
gameplay of course a a wooden Shield
even with a steel Edge or an iron Edge
is going to do absolutely nothing other
than provide a lovely Bullseye Target
for you if your enemies have guns
however we have in the collection and
you look them up on our online catalog a
number of gun Shields which are this
sort of size and shape and they have a
match lock gun set in the middle of them
little window to look through so there's
a there's a sort of realistic parallel
to this kinda
right thank you for watching guys those
were guns of bone lab quite a variety of
different guns
um lots lots to talk about hope you
enjoyed it if you'd like to check out
our Royal armories YouTube channel well
you know where to go
um we've got our three sites here in the
UK that you can visit and I'm always
banging on about and very happily happy
to say that a number of people have
visited as a result of us doing this
thank you to Gamespot for that our
social media channels as well if you'd
like to check those out but um we'll see
you again next week regardless thank you
outside
[Music]